those of you who haven't even finished
the main story episode the breath of the
wild can get there anime sweat drops of
anxiety on today because DLC is coming
and now there's even more stuff for you
to do and collect holy crap the first of
the two plans DLC packs is called the
master Trials and is launching this
summer the master Trials will add the
trial of the sword where link goes up
against waves of enemies with no armor
or weapons if he defeats all of the
enemies in the room he can proceed to
the next area and if that sounds easy
there's 45 bloody rooms in total
finishing all the trials will keep your
master sword in its powerful and glowy
form permanently though so that's good
if the legend of zelda has been too easy
for you so far the first DLC pack is
also adding a hard mode which will make
enemies rank up in difficulty slowly
recover health in battle and spot link
much easier while you're trying to
approach stealthily this DLC also packs
on a hero's path mode so you can know
where you've been and a travel medallion
that lets you create a new temporary
trouble point where you're standing if
finding all those [ __ ] is wearing down
your sanity there's a new Korek mask
which when equipped will shake if a croc
is hidden nearby finally eight new Zelda
themed pieces of equipment are coming so
now you can grab gear modeled after
characters like majora Midna phantom and
of course tingle in his very very tight
pants players can also now experience
the game in one of nine audio languages
and select a different language for
on-screen text for more info on both
upcoming DLC packs and all the others
elder e goodness subscribe and stay
tuned to games 5
you